so what can people expect in the show
it's more you more than character it's
more like standard it's it's my version
it's it's about you know instantly it's
about what happens when you don't
realize that you have gotten older I'll
tell you I went to a Steely Dan concert
recently and are you looking around I
thought oh no all that people and then I
passed the mirror me too sometimes
it's about waking up and realizing
you're not put you're not the youngest
thing in the room anymore
but all the things that that entails cuz
everything's on the floor are you
picking it up you putting it on your
head it's the whole thing and guys you
know all the stuff that happens to y'all
this was come to the show I'll tell you
everything so without really talking
about those mysterious hair loss for
women you mean the balding pudenda
that's right the balding pudenda Zenda
yeah got it
what is that Wow and ones you always do
I want to know what this I don't know if
you do but I will just put this here
there was once a time where I can't
believe you don't know yeah can you say
forget I can say it again
pubic yes
you're not a doctor but we'll select
once where there was an afro right that
I can put beads on and break
Wow yeah there is now Paul Shaffers okay
okay empty balls there we go but there's
more to it but you have to come yeah
Graham Norton here if you'd like to see
even more stuff like that then hit
subscribe or don't it's a free world but
I know what I do in that situation